stephen king disliked the movie shelley
duvall is traumatized by it the studio
went up in flames there's more stoking
the fire behind the many untold truths
of the shining masterpiece curious about
what's happening behind the overlook
hotel doors
after watching stanley kubrick's creepy
adaptation of the shining it's probably
hard for most to imagine anyone other
than jack nicholson in the role of jack
torrance however the legendary actor was
far from the only choice for the role in
his book fright favorites david j skal
says that stephen king rejected several
options that kubrick proposed for the
lead king was more of a fan of having
someone like jon voight or michael
moriarty play the role instead king
eventually accepted nicholson as jack
torrance although he wound up regretting
that decision later why you may ask it's
primarily because he criticized how
kubrick wanted the character portrayed
in an interview with deadline king
explains the character of jack torrance
has no arc in that movie absolutely no
arc at all all he does is get crazier in
the book he's a guy who's struggling
with his sanity and finally loses it to
me that's a tragedy
stephen king not only disliked how jack
torrance was portrayed in the film but
was actually even more upset with wendy
torrence in the adaptation in an
interview with the bbc he claimed that
their portrayal was misogynistic adding
she's basically just there to scream and
be stupid and that's not the woman that
i wrote about
according to the mirror the author
wanted the character to be shown as a
strong woman that he initially wrote he
even envisioned jessica lan just someone
who could do so in the end kubrick went
in a completely different direction and
dramatically changed the character he
decided to go with representing someone
more anxious and fragile and felt that
shelley duvall was a better fit for the
part
kubrick's vision of wendy torrence
illustrates a woman who is in such an
abusive relationship that she's too
frightened to leave which is
unfortunately a difficult reality that
many people face the lens that kubrick
was willing to go to get his desired
performance out of shelley duvall was
also disturbing it ultimately made
filming quite a harrowing experience for
the 28 year old actress that would have
significant long-term effects on her i
don't sympathize with shelley
it doesn't help you wouldn't it yes it
does
in an interview with dr phil many years
later it's visible that duvall is still
traumatized by the year she spent on
sets she talked about the difficulty she
went through with filming before sadly
confessing if he hadn't directed the way
he did if he hadn't done everything with
force and cruelty then i guess it
wouldn't have turned out to be as it was
not only was the casting crew ordered to
ignore and isolate duvall but kubrick
also punished her as much as possible
one of the worst examples of this is
when she was forced to do 120
takes of the scene where she holds the
baseball bat as jack nicholson slowly
stalks towards her hours of crying on
camera left her dehydrated and hoarse
and her hands even bled from holding the
bat so tightly and for long kubrick's
daughter vivian shot behind the scenes
footage for making the shining which
features various moments of tension
between duval and kubrick it even showed
duvall's hair falling out due to the
unbearable stress of filming
one of the key features shared by both
the novel and the film is the eerie
atmosphere of the overlook hotel but do
you know what inspired it it's actually
based upon the stanley hotel in estes
colorado in late september 1974 stephen
king and his wife spent time at the
stanley hotel when it was nearly empty
as a resort was about to close for
winter the silent holes and spooky
ambience creeped the author out so much
that it led to a nightmare that will
become the origin for the shining the
hotel has a long history of being
haunted in fact according to the new
york times the owners and staff have
leaned into the spooky image of the
stanley and used it as a marketing
strategy they've even gone as far as
adding the hedge maze kubrick created
for his film in 2015.
filming the shining may not have been as
hard for the rest of the cast and crew
as it was for duvall but it was still
extremely difficult a number of takes
kubrick wanted to shoot for every scene
and the numerous changes to the script
increased the shooting schedule from six
months to over a year as seen in the
behind the scenes documentary jack
nicholson reportedly gave up memorizing
the script due to the daily rewrites
instead he'd just do a quick study of
the scene prior to filming everybody's
got their script out you can look right
over and know if they've got the latest
version but of course you'll never have
the latest version
70 year old scotsman crothers also
suffered due to coo bricks perfectionism
according to the guardian kubrick
demanded 60 retakes for one scene which
made crothers cry in exasperation yet
none of these were as high as the shine
scene whose 148 retakes earned it the
guinness world record for most retakes
for one scene with dialogue however
there were some in the crew who didn't
mind all of the retakes in an interview
with the independent steadicam operator
garrett brown said i realized on day one
it was a priceless opportunity for me to
perfect what i was doing really to learn
the physical act of doing it i could
have literally done 100 takes or 1 000
takes
since its release king has expressed
criticisms of the film that boiled down
to his frustration over the various
changes from his original version after
praising the look of the film in an
interview with deadline king admitted
when it's opened a lot of the reviews
weren't very favorable and i was one of
those reviewers i kept my mouth shut at
the time but i didn't care for it much
among his problems with the film king
felt that in kubrick's hands the overall
story is darker and more heartless than
what he envisioned he summed it up as
such to tcm saying i always thought that
the real difference between my take on
it and stanley kubrick's take on it was
this in my novel the hotel burns in
kubrick's movie the hotel freezes it's
the difference between warmth and cold
as grueling as it was filming the
shining apparently didn't impact the
child actors as much as the adults in an
interview with the guardian danny lloyd
describes how kubrick did what he could
to protect him from the scary aspects of
the shining so he wouldn't be scarred
for life in fact kubrick was so
successful that lloyd didn't even know
he was in a horror film and not a drama
until years later but danny
unfortunately struggled to find success
after the film and quit acting when he
was 13 or 14. however lloyd wasn't the
only child actor of the shining to make
that decision lisa and louise burns
played the creepy and iconic grady twins
[Music]
come and play with us daddy
in spite of their success on screen they
decided to focus on academic pursuits
rather than careers and film years later
the pair appeared in an episode of vh1's
where are they now but they describes
their decidedly less creepy lives out of
the spotlight
twenty years after the release of his
novel king got his chance to redeem his
original story and tell it the way he
wanted to for television audiences the
shining miniseries was written and
produced by the horror master it's later
aired on abc in three parts in 1997.
featuring stephen weber as jack and
rebecca de mourney as wendy the small
screen adaptation shows the characters
in a way that is more true to how they
are written in the novel not only does
the mourner play a much stronger
character but it's also made clear that
webber's portrayal of jack truly
showcases the evil influence of the
undead the overlooked hotel is the main
cause of his descent into madness the tv
miniseries got a number of positive
reviews by critics and even won two emmy
awards for makeup and sound editing
one of the many hard to believe
conspiracy theories about the film's
secret messages is also one of the
darkest the theory is put forward in a
thorough analysis by film scholar rob
aeger in his book mazes mirrors
deception and denial and focuses on the
disturbing bear suit scene in the film a
man dressed in a bear costume performs a
sexual act on another man bears are a
recurring motif in kubrick's film and in
fact their image is associated with dany
several times in the movie aegin knows
that the use of this bear imagery
connects dany to the man in the bear
costume this frighteningly speaks to a
much darker and more sinister subtext
dany has been sexually abused by jack
agar points to other evidence of this
potential trauma he points out the
playgirl issue that jack is reading
which features a story with the title
incest why parents sleep with their
children there's also the similar use of
a mirror between dany's dream sequence
in room 237 where jack meets the rotting
old woman and the disturbing scene where
jack comforts dany while aegis
interpretation is his own even the
theory makes jack even more of a monster
than he already is
along with interpretations of the best
suit mystery there are many other
theories of hidden meanings throughout
the film kubrick was a well-known
perfectionist so when even a minor
detail is off many are quick to find
some logical reason for the discrepancy
but producer jan harlan is very clear
about his dismissal of the conspiracy
theory surrounding the film in an
interview with entertainment weekly he
says the most insulting one is the idea
that the shining is a film about the
holocaust that's outrageous that's an
insult to kubrick and also an insult to
victims of the holocaust the other ideas
are much more harmless where continuity
mistakes are attributed with deep
meaning it's difficult to argue with
harlan on this since according to the
independent kubrick actually did want to
make a film about the holocaust and
spent over 20 years developing a project
called the aryan papers which never came
to fruition
one condition that kubrick made warner
brothers agree to was that all the news
footage had to be destroyed as producer
jan harlan shared with entertainment
weekly stanley wanted to make sure that
nobody would ever reassemble his edit in
any other way the first of the unused
scenes show jack finding a scrapbook
that illustrates the dark events of the
overlooks past even though the scene did
not make the final cut the scrapbook can
still be seen on his desk for a moment
later in the film because it was so
important to the story as a result the
very end which shows the photograph of
jack from 1921 makes even less sense
without that cut scene it's good to see
you
it's good to be back lloyd kubrick also
took out an alternate ending because
warner brothers thought the movie was
too long after jack's famous demise in
the cold the scene shows wendy and dany
safe in a hospital the alternate ending
continues with the manager of the
overlook hotel telling them that an
investigation was done and no evidence
of paranormal activity has been found
however he follows that admittance by
handing dany the same tennis ball he
found outside the haunted room 237
ultimately leaving the audience
convinced of the supernatural events
they just witnessed
as if the filming of the shining could
not get any more chaotic the independent
reported that things took an even more
intense turn when a fire broke out at
elstree studios where the majority of
the film was shot luckily no one was
harmed but the flames caused all sorts
of damage kubrick not only seemed
unfazed but was even a bit happy about
the disaster in an interview with bbc
his widow kristiana kubrick says it gave
him a long delay which for some reason
he thought was quite fun because he
could rethink certain things raymarine
the sound editor also comments on how
the director only seems concerned with
making sure his audio recordings were
safe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror masterpieces are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]